in the previous session I had asked you
to find the number of different possible
anagrams of Mook can be sold this using
the same concept we saw in the previous
session where we made four slots
let's try as there are four letters the
first slot can be filled in four ways
after using up one letter here three
remain for the second slot three ways in
which the second slot can be filled
after using a letter each in the first
two slots to remain for the third slot
two ways in which it can be filled and
just one letter remains for the fourth
slot and we multiply these to get the
answer twenty four ways in which
different anagrams of Mook can be formed
for factorial what we saw is incorrect
and a very common mistake made by
students the important thing that we
need to observe here is that there are
two O's in Mook 1 M 1 C and two O's so
what if there are two O's will it matter
to understand this let's assume for time
being that the two O's are different
let's call them or 1 and O 2 assuming
they are different let's look at a few
anagrams one would be M or one or two C
and another one would be M C or 1 or 2
now assuming the O's are different
can we write the first one as M o 2 or 1
C yes we can
as the O's are assumed to be different
and we can write the second one as M C
or two or one look at the first pair in
reality are they different is mook
different from MOOC no they're the same
the two O's are not different that is
just one o in the English alphabet what
about the second pair is MC o or
different from MC o oh no they're the
same as well this is what 4 factorial
includes it counts each anagram twice
which is incorrect
why is 4 factorial counting each anagram
twice the answer to this question is
important so let me have your complete
attention for the next 1 minute assuming
the O's to be different there are two
fact
Oriol arrangements for each anagram the
two factorial arrangements for each
anagram are or one or two and auto or
one but should we count - are they yours
different no they are not so we should
count just one of each pair and that is
why we should divide all possibilities
by 2 factorial 4 factorial includes all
possibilities assuming each letter is
distinct but here the two O's are not
distinct so we divide 4 factorial by 2
factorial many books will simply ask you
to divide 4 factorial by 2 factorial as
these are 4 letters and out of these 4
two are the same but you must understand
why we're doing it in the all
possibilities case each anagram is
counted two factorial times so we
divided by 2 factorial to eliminate the
repeated anagrams what if we had another
row something like mukou it's easy how
many letters do we have in all 5 so 5
factorial will include all possible
anagrams assuming the o's are different
but we have three o's here so to
eliminate the repeated ones we divide 5
factorial by 3 factorial so here's
another one which I want you to try find
the number of different anagrams
possible for the word excessive it's
simple
how should we go about an anagram
problem in your exams the previous
method we saw would be a bit tedious so
here is an easier approach the first
thing we should do is count the number
of letters in the word same or not just
count them one two three four five six
seven eight and nine nine letters the
word excessive has nine letters once we
count the number of letters in the word
we should check if any of the letters
are repeated so let's go letter by
letter the first letter is e how many
times does he appear in the word do we
see more ease yes there are two more
ease
it appears three times and all now we
can move on to the second letter it's X
it appears just once what about C just
once e is already considered s it
appears twice S appears two times I and
V appear just once
and the last e has already been
considered once this is ready getting to
the answer is very simple nine letters
so all possibilities assuming all
letters are distinct would be 9
factorial the letter e appears three
times so we divide this by 3 factorial
and as s appears twice we divided by 2
factorial this is our answer if you
solve it you will get 30,000 240 as the
number but you wouldn't really need to
the answer choices you would have in
your exams would most probably be in the
factorial form so we can have these many
anagrams of the word excessive
you